[Music]
hey guys in this mkbhd video we're going
to be taking a look at the youtube tips
video episode number one so keep in mind
you can click the corner of this video
to view the overall overview of this
series which is where you can leave
suggestions for more episodes so i've
been getting the question a lot you know
where did i start on youtube how did i
start out even before i got to t2i or
before i even was accepted into the
youtube partner program
now it's there's a whole bunch of
different types of videos you can get
into
and those include science and technology
comedy and several others and i'll be
focusing on science and technology which
is a smaller niche it's no surprise that
the vast majority of the top 20 or so
most subscribed channels on youtube are
all comedy
but we're going to be taking a look at
mostly science and technology for this
series and uh the first thing i want to
talk about is actually building uh from
ground zero and really starting from
point zero and maybe you wanna make your
own tech videos kind of like i do so
without any further ado let's take a
look
the first thing to do is to select your
tech video type you can either be
software hardware or tech news and of
course a combination of the three which
is what i try to do is really good but
the easiest to start off with is
software and that's what i started off
with and software is really easy to get
started with because there's a free
software out there that i've done videos
on called cam studio which is a style uh
called screencasting which literally
takes the software and records your
screen with what it's uh when the
software is running so you can get
started with free software you really
don't need much to edit this kind of
stuff as long as you can you know move
your mouse around and show things and if
you're good at that you can get a good
portion of your audience interested in
what you have to show next in software
now tech news is another niche that's
definitely very saturated right now
there are the big youtubers like locker
gnome and john four lakers and soldier
knows best who literally do this full
time and as soon as something comes out
on the market they are really on top of
it so if you're going to do tech news
you're going to have to do something
different it seems difficult to really
separate yourself and i try to do a
different style of video you can see you
know annotations over on the right hand
side
and to really separate yourself and get
started with tech news you're going to
have to do something really different
and get started with video editing which
is going to be a later episode then the
last but not least uh most important
type of tech video is hardware
now you can get started you're going to
need a camera of course for doing
hardware videos and tech news videos
usually but the thing you're going to
need to do is get gadgets to review now
yes there will be a separate video on
getting video you know gadget review
stuff uh and if you want to you can
start off with reviewing things you
already have which is what i did i
actually purchased my laptop which was
what really got me started in making
videos and i bought a laptop cooler and
said you know what i'm gonna take the
laptop webcam
pointing out the box and just film me
taking out of the box and that was my
first hardware video ever uploaded to
youtube and this is really how a lot of
you guys can get started if you have a
little flip video camera if you get
something like that for christmas that's
going to be pretty helpful you can get
started on youtube that way
next thing you're going to want to do is
pick a channel name this is something
you're going to want to identify
yourself by i didn't really have an idea
of what i was going to do on my youtube
channel when i started of course i just
picked marcus brownlee because that's my
name but i did get youtube.com mkbhd
that channel as well is much easier to
remember
and mapped with partner branding
so you can of course view my new channel
background there uh just finished
redesigning that it's embarrassing how
long it took to make but i'm really
proud of it so in the next episode we're
going to be taking a look at graphics
and getting your channel background set
up and your logo and really identifying
yourself on youtube but this just been a
quick tip on the types of tech videos to
get you started on youtube and hopefully
i've helped you out in the next episode
you can click the corner of this video
and view that so merry christmas if
you're watching this on christmas happy
new year and i'll see you in 2011. peace
[Music]
[Music]
you